Aihaisenta, on petkiä palaveria, yötä myötä, kyllähän siinä muutakin täytyy nauttia, kuin kansalaisluottamusta, aika pikkuina viinatilkka, ta voisko hyvä hallitus, tehdä edes yhden päätöksen, sylvintäri.
Tutut sanat, eli tervetuloa mukaan ja matkaan. Tässä ajaksossa kuullaan ajatuksia esimerkiksi lapsista, ruuasta ja eläimistä.
Puolituntisen kommentit on kolautellut kohdilleen, koiviston Lauri.
Korossa pohdintoja kielestämme.
Mapetsu, morjesta.
Morjes, morjes.
Kyselisi semmoista, ihmettele, että katoaako suomen kieli kokonaa, koska nykyään puhutaan ou lukkia, dinneriä, master bedroomia, spaatea, fi-diningia, podiumia, outfitia ja tämmöstä.
Sit oli yks keres, sisutu soimaan, meni kattoo ihan normaali kämppäni, nainen sanoi, et onpa ihana vinsit lukki täs master bedroomissa, ja sit meni normaali kylpäri, ni se oli spa.
Ohta ei puhuta Suomea, valitettavasti Suomessa ollenkaa.
Kuinka laajena ilmiönä tällä hetkellä näet tämän asian?
No, mainokset ja sieletkari tulevat, nimenomaan, ja sitten radiosta ja jengi, ku puhuu tuolainen, puhuu just tämmöstä kieltä, pitää heittää jotain, vaan tii sen se kava, minkä maan kieltä toi nyt saattuu olemaankaan.
Oletko huolissasi?
Kyllä se nyt vähän harmittaa, että suomen kieli pikku hiljaa katoa, murteet ja kaikki tämmösen.
Mitä asialle pitäisi tehdä?
Sulle tää puhuu, vaska samvoja, mitä kaiken maan porhin kieltä täältä Suomesta löytyy.
Ihan peritettä Suomen kieltä, ni se oli paljon moikeeppaa.
Äänää, minua ainammat tiimista varmaa ymmärräkää tollenkaa, mitä nää hölisee ja pölisee radiossa ja televisiossa.
Kiitoksia paljon tästä soitosta, ja hyvää syyspäiväjatkoa.
Joo, kiitos samoin, moi.
Seuraavaksi palaamme vahvasti koulun penkille.
Olen Andiamurisotkomustan, haluaisin osallistua lisää tutkimuksessa, keskusteluihin, omalla mielipiteilläni.
Entäpä, jos lapset ovat ennen saaneet ollakin pikempää lapsia, leikkiä omiaan mielikuvitusleikkejaan ja kehittyä omaa luovuuttaan.
Ei osallistuja taitoja, tokuutettu liian aikaisin, vaan kehittytty omaa tahtia.
Ope, ev, peiroittaa. Juuri uutisia katsoin, ja huomaan, että suomalaisten lasten pisa-tutkimukset ovat menneet alaspäin ku lehmän häntä.
Suurimpiirtein samassa taadissa, ilmeisesti, kun meidän taloussakkaa ja yhteiskunta tekee muitakin semmoisia päätöksiä,
jotka ovat tietysti lastenkoulumenestykseen vaikuttaneet.
Onko tämä nyt se ikäluokka? Ne vanhat, ne ikäluokat, jotka nyt päättävät Suomen asioista,
joka pilaa lasten elämän totaalisesti.
Menee koulumenestys, menee talous, menee elämän yleinen rauha.
On se kauheaa perintö, kun näiden lasten vanhemmat jättää lapsillensa yhteiskuntakuralla.
Kaikki aikaisemmat menestykset ovat olleet ollut maailman kärkilokkaa, nyt ne ovat maailman häntäpää.
Meille ei sovi tällainen hallintomalli, meille ei sovi tällainen politiikka.
Politiikot ovat möhlineet tämän yhteiskunnan täysin.
No, Hannele Tampereelta, terve.
Terve, terve.
Olla on noussut syvä huoli lasten uimaopetuksesta ja sen riittävyydestä.
Kun tota, niin tässä nyt on jo otunutte vähän yrittämään olla sorminapilla ja varaamaan uimakoulupaikkaa,
semmoiselle kuusvuotiaille, ennen koulua, että olisis joku tuntuma, ei vaan riitä.
Uimaopetus tarjontaa liian vähän, vai?
Nii, nopeat, vain nopeat elävät siinä vaiheessa, ja ne, jotka ei tota kerkeä, niin ne hukkuu.
No, kyllä jo. No ei, koulujen, opetusohjelman näköjään kyllä kuuluu perusopetukseen uimaopetusta,
mutta näihin vapaaehtoisiin, jotka olis niinku ennen koulua menossa, niin niihin ei vaan mahdu.
Ja se on mun mielestä huono juttu.
Onko mitää ehdotusta, että miten asia voisi hoitaa paremmin?
Siiis arvontahan, nyt se aina on semmoinen hyvä asia.
Tei tarvis niinku mummien ja muitten sukulaisteni olla siellä aamuseittemältä jonottamassa.
Varaus on aamuseittemältä.
No se alkaa sitten aamusta, joo.
Niin ne, jotka vanhemmat ei tietysti pääse töistänsä semmoisiin, mutta joo, tää on niinku se juttu, että olis niinkun, sittenhän niitä on kyllä, joo, mutta on semmoisiin aikoihin, ettei vanhemmat pääse viemään niitä lapsia, eikä mummitkaa kaikki oo siellä eläkkeellä.
Uimakouluja lisää, nii.
Kiitoksia, paljon tästä puhelusta.
Hyvä, kiitos.
No nyt ku omenoita on nii paljon taas tänä vuonna ni, ehdottaisin tällaista, että veisitte koululle.
Hummo tai pappani veis koululle ompuja, vai oppilaat sais ompuja kans.
Siinä päästiin ompuihin, ja syömishommissa jatkammekin, siis hyvää ruokahalua.
Minua on vähän alkaa ihminen, että minkä takia on aina asiakkaa vika, jos realistuslaitokset tekee niinkun nyt minä olin reisuseet leipää voitelemassa, et on asiakkaa vikaiten, he kuluttaa niipaan markariinille.
Nyt esimerkiksi leipää on ilmestynyt, kun he eivät osaa käyttää oikeita tyyppisiä jauhoja, tai sitten he kovottaa hiivan kanssa.
Ja jos te, yrittäjät, ovat itse, niin tyhmiä, ettei tajuata vikauheista itsessään, niin he eivät pistetää sitä ainakaan asiakkaisyyksi, joka maksaa sen leivään.
Ja, mitä se olisi, oisitteko? Heillä olisi vähän niinko itse tutkistoon paikka, minun miesten ja aina. Morjen.
No hiihtäjä tässä hei.Kummosta, kun on tätä maitoallergiaa, tuntuu olevan nyt erittäin paljon täällä Itä-Suomessa, niin tuota, tai ainakin heidän perillisillä, olivat he missä tahansa, niin täällä on puohia ollut vielä kotieläiminäni.
Viimeisen sodan jälkeen, jopa kaupunkipaikossa, ja työkaveri kertoi, että hänen tytär syntyjä, se lehmän maito ei sopinut, tässä todetti, se ei sopi, ja sitten eräs lääkäri keksii, että kannattaako vielä vuohen maitoa, ja se oli pelastus.
Onko nämä verinnöllisiä sitten niillä ihmisillä, noiden esivanhemmat on pitkään, juoneet vuohen maitoa, ja siirrytti lehmän maitoa, joka ei heille sopinut.
No, tää on kotkassa päivään, kuulla semmoinen juttu on, kun nyt on paljon hedelmiä tarjouksessa tuolla kaikissa kaukoissa, ja minäkin ostin satsi, ostin luumuja, ja persikoita, mitä nää nyt oli, mut sitten kun mä tulin kotiin, niin arvatkaa mitä, ne kaikki hedelmät on ihan raakoja.
Se on raakoja paketoitu, myydään sitten tuota semmoisissa kahden euron pakkauksissa.
Minä tulen kyllä sitä mieltä, et raoilla hedelmillä on liian iso maksu, et minkä tähdenne pitää myydä raakana? Hei.
Hei sinnekin, nyt on vuorossa ajatuksia viime jaksojen puheenaiheisiin.
Enen puheluita yksi kansaridion verkkosivujen lomakkeella lähetty teksti.
Viime ohelmaa kuunnellessani tulin siihen tulokseen, että Alavus, ja miksei koko Etelä-Pohjanmaa tulisi erottaa Suomesta,
Näisen asukkaat pääsi pois EU:n kurimuksesta.
Ajatusten Lapuanjoki ja Lakeuden Nero, Nymerkki oli lähettänyt tämän tekstin kansaradion verkkosivujen lomakkeella.
Viime sunnuntain lähetyksessä oli todella harvinaisen fiksu nainen soittelemassa, ei sen puolelle naiset on kyse fiksuja aina.
Hänellä oli aivan samantyyppisiä ajatuksia kuin minullakin, nimittäin tästä naamioituneena esiintymisestä oikeuden istunnossa.
Meillä oli purkalla viime lauantaina naamieset, siellä meillä oli kaikilla aivan hauskaa, ja oltiin naamiaisarussa, mutta se on taas aivan eri asia.
Miten voi olla todellakin mahdollista, että oikeuden istuntoa voidaan tulla naamioituneena johonkin takinalle lehden taakse piiloutuneena?
Jos on miehellä munaa tehdä rikoksia, niin pitäis olla sen verran munaa, että pystyy niihin omilla kasvoillaan vastaamaan, omista tekemisistään.
Ei pidä olla tommosia raukkoja.
Kytä mä sanoo, tää ei oo mies eikään mikään tolainen juippi, joka piilottelee siellä toppatakin sisällä.
Kylä jonkunlainen roti pitäis saada, eikö tuomareillakaan kieltäis tämmösen esiintymisen?
Minä oon kaastalla mega pälkäneltä, se on moro.
Seellä rariossa yks vaari ilmoitti notta, televisiossa näkyy alavareisa alastomia naisia.
Tarvii heti ilmoittaa notta, miltä kanavalta niitä näkyy.
Tierottakaa, hyvä, kansan rarion väki heti.
Onneksi olkoon sata vuotta yle, ja T.S. esim. lauantai aamupäilisen on hauska kuunnella, kun toimittaja Haapakangassa ynnä, hänen kollegaansa puhuvat siellä murretta nii kovasti.
Lauri oli siellä.
Lauri täällä, hyvääpä.
Ole, tota, niitä Pohjoismaiden yhdistymisestä.
Joo, siellä oli tällainen, tota.
Erittää vakavasti otettava ja erittää hyvää.
Iuttu, toivoisin, että sais paljo kannatusta ja Suomen hallituksessakin, jollakin ois nämä elimet nimeltä korvat ollu päässä kuulolla. Mitä toi kaveri juttu?
Tosiaan, viime Kansanradiossa ehdotti tällaista Pohjoismaiden liittoumaa, niin miksi tällainen olisi mielestäsi hyvä?
Mehä ollaan jo muutenkin, niinkun Suomi, Ruotsi, Norja, Tanska, tavallaan Islattiki, niin meillähän on paljon yhteistä.
Tivistys, koulutus, työntekovaihtoa, meillä työntekijävaihtoa, ja meillä on hyvä taloustilanne ja talousfoorumi, kun ajatellaan, monen muun, niinkun tuossa oli juttu, että ei voi verrata välimeden maa. Ei, koska tuota, meillä on koulumaailma, kaikki arvot on samanlaista.
Hinnottomasti olisi sitä mieltä, että erittäin kannatettava ideaalistua.
Mielestäsi, suomalaisten politikkojen pitäisi ruveta ajamaan tällaisesta Pohjoismaiden unionia.
Kyl, ihan tosi mielellä, koska tuota ei siitä, ainaka huonommaks voi mennä, EU napisee jo nyt, liitoksissaan nii palju, ni mieluummin olisi niinkun yhtenäinen vahva Pohjola. Olen sitä mieltä.
Kiitän oikein paljon sitä saveriaa, joka oli väittänyt sulle tämän viestin sinne, että oli hyvin selkeästi ilmaistu tahtotila.
Kiitoksia paljon tästä kannatuspuheenvuorosta, ja hyvää pyhäpäiväjatkoa.
Kuin myös, ja oikein hyvää pyhäpäiväjatkoa, teinecki kansanradion kuulijat. Moi!
Tämän kerran politiikkapaketti tarjoillaan kahdessa osassa, niistä ensimmäinen on hyvin talouspainotteinen.
No, iletas tässä, hei!
Miksi aina Suomen taloutta verrataan Ruotsin talouteen?
Koska on muitakin maita olemassa kuin Ruotsi.
Verrattavissa Suomeen esimerkis on Itävalta, Saksa, ja Hollanti, ja kaikki muut Euroopan maan.
Aina otetaan verrannolliseksi Ruotsi, ettei muuta sitte ku ette ku moi.
No moi!
Olen tässä kuunnellu näitä turran kehuja, kuinka ostavoima lisääntyy, ku nytte sitten
Tielituloseita tätä aletetaan veroja.
Tosin sanottiin vähän niinku vaihihkaa, että
tielituloseille jää käteen enemmän kaksisata euroa vuodesta.
Nii, mikä tekee sitten puukatta kohti kuustaus euroa kuuskyt kuus sentti?
Kyllä, siinä ostavoima varmaa kohoa.
No, täältä Jyväskylä liepirataa siltaa.
Kuutevin äsken tossa näitten ekonomistien alaveria kesti vajaa tunnin,
ja siellä puhuttiin asiallisesti tärkeistä asioista.
Vielä ei ois pärjänny ykskään politiikko niissä kisoissa, ei ainutkaan.
Eiks voittais tehdä semmonen perustuslainemuutos, että äärilaitojen puolueet, nämä jyrkät puolueet,
pitäis samalla tavalla ku Saksassa, on ikuisesti päätetty, että eivät tule enää takaisin.
Viks ei voitais tehdä Suomessakin sama juttu?
Tulis jotai järkeä nähi hommii. Kiitos, moi.
Sakortijan puolen on pistäny yli sata erottajaa nimensä, jotta näiden riikikeskuksien pitäis tuottaa itte omat sähkensä.
Vehkä, ja siihen kyllä oo, ja niillä on kyllä rahaa.
Nyt ei sen kummempaa.
Ei sen kummempaa siellä, päätöksentekoa koskevin kommenteen jatketaan eteenkin päin.
Enen seuraavia äänimuotoisia ajatuksia, vielä yksi sähköposti, jossa lukee näin.
Täällä kuuntelijaa risoo hallituksen toiminta.
Perussuomalaiset saavat nelviä ja solvata ihmisiä saamatta mitään rangaistuksia.
Peltokankaan rasistiset kommentit painattiin villaisella, ei sanktioita.
Samanlaisia rasistisia kommentteja on tullut vähän väliä, eikä niistä seuraa mitään.
Orpoa viedään kuin pässiä narusta.
Rasismin vastaiseen toimintaan käyttiin kuusi miljoonaa euroa, mihinkä ne rahat menivät, kun sama touhu jatkuu.
Toivottavasti äänestäjät miettivät, ketä äänestävät.
Näin lukee sähköpostissa, jonka meillä oli lähettä nymerkki, hallituksen touhuun kyllästynyt.
Kansanradion sähköpostiosoite on kansan.radio@yle.fi.
Eihä siitä aina tolokkua tuu siitä hommasta, mutta tuota, ihmettele minä vaan, että tuonne politiikkaa sitä riittää tuota rahaa vaan, ei mihinkään muualle.
Se oo semmoista peliä, niillikasta peliä ku olla ja vaan voi.
Miksi kansan edustajat ja ministerit eivät koskaan puhu omista palkoistaan ja niiden leikkauksista?
Esimerkiksi, ne kaikki sopeutumiseläkkeet, niitä pitää verottaa piitskymmentä prosenttia. Ne on niille aivan turhaa. Ei ne tarvii niitä. No nii, hepa.
No se on tieltä Savoista, vaan yks semmoinen, joka välillä kuunteloo tätä teidän mukavata ohjelmaa.
Hyvää päivää.Päivää. Tuossa tyli mieleen, tuossa jokunne aika sitten, ni uutisia lukivat tuolta Amerikan muualta,
että siellä tämä rumpi on keksinä oikein hyvä vaalijutu. Se on ruvenna ottamaan iäni, ja se maksaa isot rahat, jos voittaa vaalit.
Tässä ois meijenni rahamiehille oikein maeini ja konstituutapana vaaliin töpinätä, ja ruppais vaalit kiinnostamaan ja äänestys kiinnostamaan.
Tässä ei meillä tarvitaa muuta ku muutetaan lakia, vahta ei se iänen ostaminen oo en erikois niinku tähän Männessä on.
Kyllä ne pannaan siinä työttömät ja opiskelijat maksamaan, ja silt niitähän tarah olee, et se onhan maksettua tämmöset luppaakset.
Ja tällä tavalla se onhan Suomi tois hirvee hyvästi nous.
Oisiko tää mielestäsi jo paikallaan, ensi vuoden eduskuntavaaleissa, että ostettaisi nääniä?
No, kyllä, mielellään, jos vaan tuota ois kerkis vanliäkkiä lakia muuttoa.
Tämähän pistäs koko Suomen nousuun katot, tuota ku rahaa miehille, tämä ois ainaki oikein mahdollinen, hyvä, tai tappas, että rahaa lasua piä huosella piäs.
No nii, kiitoksia naista ajatuksista, ja hyvää syyspäivänjatkoa.
Kiitos, ihan sammus, moi.
Hei, hei.
Olen RK.Oon viime päivinäan paljon puhuttu yritysten tuista ja näistä muista, mutta kenenkään sakset eivät ole osuneet tänne puoluetukin.
Lehtitietojen mukaan, sitä on jaettu tänä vuonna yli 34 miljoonaa.
Ja mielestäni se on kohtuutonta ajatella näitä kaikkia muita supistuksia.
Onhan puolueiden tietysti mukava käydä risteilyllä kavereiden kanssa ja kierpää maata kertomassa, mitä ovat saaneet aikaan tai mitä tulevat tekemään.
Mutta, kaikki veromaksejat eivät halua tähän liittyä.
Siksi keksin keinon, laitetaan veroilmotukseen ruutu, johon jokainen veromakseja saa laittaa haluamansa puolueen kohdalle täpän, ja siitä pidätetään puoluet tuki heille.
Näin jokainen saa itse päättää, ketä haluaa tukea.
Ja varmasti nykyään IT-alaralla on helppo lisätä nämä ruudut veroilmoitukseen. Kiitos, hei.
Loputetaan oveen.
Ja sisään astuu annos liikenneaiheita.
Puheluita edeltää tämä WhatsApp-sovelluksessa lähetty viesti.
Kyllä minä niin mieleni pahoitin, kun ajokortin uusintaan varasin ajanlääkärille.
Siinähän nuori naislääkäri värkäsi jos jonkinlaista, joka ei minusta ollut oikein terveyden kartoittamista.
Ja sitten tämä lysti maksoi 250 euroa, selvää rahastusta.
Tällä tavoin luki WhatsApp-viestissä, jonka meillä oli lähettänyt Veikko.
Meille kansarioon voi lähettää WhatsApp-viestejä, sekä äskeisenlaisia tekstimuotoisia, että myös ääniviestejä.
Kansaridon WhatsApp-numero on 0, 4, 4, 5, 5, 1, 5, 4, 6, 4.
Onahan se nyt, kun kaikkea verotetaan.
Auton polttoaineet on kalliita.
Nytähän nämä sähkö, vempelee kuljettajat.
Kun sähköautot painaa enemmän kaiken teknologian takia, isot renkaat, painavat autot.
Kuluttaahan neki tieverkostoa enemmän ku kevyemmet polttofotoriset autot.
Ja niitäkin voisi verottaa sitten, et saada noit tiet parempaa kuntoon.
Et veroa sahkoautoillekin, et kuluttavat teitä, sama veroja enemmänkin. Kiitos.
Pera terven.Semmästi rupeisin soittelemaan nyt tästä valtioan touhosta, kun volttaen esinnä taussee ihan piliviä.
Se on suuri rosuahan, tässä on Suomen valtio, ja sitten nää päätteet, mitkä sen on, enää tuonut tyhtää joustavaa.
Tetää me nyt kyllä mallisette, kohta ei oo varää esimisevää, enää työmatköhkaa.
Nee vaan herras van ku hertelee silassa eduskunta saavansa kuppiloissa.
Nee kyllä on Suomen asia tuonut, ne kyllä on eikoseen mallia.
Se parannekaa niinkauko tää rusa ja kurvan porukku, se se touhuu.
Ja tässä on aikamone, se kasvat ku nyt kyllä, autori ja moni muut yrittäjä.
Ihmeessään toi volttaen esinnäkäs.
Ene ei ota yhtään malli, ku joka vaikka sanottaa ruotsista malli,
miksei nyt otau tässä volttaen esinnasta.
Se kyllä muunistui tämmönen ihan tekahoksi koko hommaa,
ja joko on puhunutki, että yleislahko vaan pistää tästä volttaen esinnasta,
eikä ne tule ymmärtämään, mistä on kyse.
Täämmössä tää oli noin, tätä yhtäksella.
Autoilijat, jotka ei osaa tota vilkua käyttää.
Pitäskö ne pistää uudesta autokouluun?
Ja sitten toinen asia, minkä vois siellä oppia, se turvaväli.
Silloin, ku ajetaa tuolla Suomen maantielle,
miss on kilometreittää tilaa sinne su tänne,
niin se helpottais kaikkien ajamista, kun ei roikuttais siinä puskurissa.
Mutta on nyt yksi hyväkin uutinen tullut,
että nuorten naisten ja miesten tuloerot on kaventuneet.
Tarkottaisiko tää nyt sitä, että saatais lisää miehiä myös naisvaltaisille aloille?
Se tekisi tuöyhteisöille todellakin hyvää.
Hämärä tulee jo ajoissa, eikä aamulla näkyvyys ole sen parempi.
On sateita ja sumuja.
Kiitos kaitule vanhemmille, jotka ovat jo aloittaneet näiden pienten heijastin kampanjat,
ja opetellaan täyttämään ajoissa.
Kiitos myös koirien ulkoiluttajille.
Koirillehan on myöskin näitä heijastimia.
Näkyi sitten ne pienimmätkin kulkiat.
Taljoka, syksyinen asia, ja ihmisistä muuttuu, goottilaisia.
Vaatteet tummenevat, kenkiä myöten, muistetaan näkyvyys,
ja katsotaan oikealle ja vasemmalle kunnenen koulujen lähellä.
Muistutuksia, toivon myös yleltä, näin ajoissakin.
Kiitos hei.
Naopa, seikirää valtaterve.
Mua on pikkuisen huolestutta, ihan suoraan sanottuna näiden nuorten lasten,
tämä kännykän käyttö pyöhäilessä.
Eli, et ajetaan pyöhällä, ja katsotaan samaa aikaa kännykkää.
Ja se on nyt ihan niinkun, jo, tietysti aikuiset tekee tätä samaa myös autoilessa,
mikä on mun mielestä ihan melkein niinkun velkeinen, enemmän huolestuttavaa,
mutta tähän voisi niinkun jollain tavalla niinkun joku, en tiedä, joku,
nii, ainahan se on joku, ottaa huomiota, et se ei oo kauhean järkevää.
Tällainen niinkun vaara onnettomuukselle on aikamoisen suuri.
Eli, pidetää ne kännykät silloin, kun ollaan liikenteessä,
vaikka kävellestäkin, tai pyöhällestä, tai autolesta, nyt pidetää ne ihan taskussa,
ja tota, sitten tehdään niiden kanssa jotain muuta silloin, kun tota, niille kuuluu.
Tällaista niinkun tässä ajatellaan. Moi moi.
Eläin asiaa on luvassa nyt seuraavaksi. Niitä ennen muisto,
että kansaradyn jakso ilmestyy Yle Areenaan, joka perjantai kello 21.
Jos merkkaat sydämen kuvasta, ja tilaat ohjelmasta ilmoitukset kellon kuvasta,
nii saat aina ensimmäinen tiedon, kun uusi jakso ilmestyy Yle Areenaan.
Joo, eläkeläinen täältä soittelee jälleen kerran.
Kuule, olen etsinnyt pitkään kissaa kaveriksi kerrostalo asuntoon niiden.
Kun tuo kävely oo hankalaa niiden, niin kissahan ei tarvitse ulkoiluttaa,
et se kävelee tässä sisällä sitten niiden, kun koirahan pität käyttää kolmet kertaa päiväs,
vähintää ulkoan kävelyttämässä.
Sitten laitoin netti ilmoituksen, että tahaku juttuun, että lahjoitetaan kissoja.
Sitten tuli vastaus sitten, että tohon eläinsuojelupalveluun,
mikä on täällä Lahdessa niiden, Jokimaalla, soitiin sinne.
Kissan hinta ois kuuse puolsataa euroa.
Ku ei se tarvis olla muuta ku maatiaiskissa.
Että ku ne on sirutettu ja rokotettu niitä, ja sitten toi sirut,
ne maksaa kuulemma kolkytä euroa, jos sen käyttää ite eläilääkärillä.
Miiin tää perustuu, tää homma, sit ei se mitään lahjottamista oo,
kuuse puolstata euroa kissasta.
Ja ennen maatilolla niitä oli paljon tiipa liikaakin niitä,
nykyään maatilolla ko ei enää kissoja niitä.
Miiin ne oon oikee hävinne, hävistamaan vähän vanhempikin kissa,
sillä mitää väliää on niitä.
Niin, se ois nii hyvä seurakaveri tossa noita kävelee jalkojen vieressä niiden niiden.
Niin, nii, nii.
Semmasa, että mistähän et mahtas löytää?
Ja se, ku tietää, ni ilmotelkaa.
Hyvä, kiitos, Heivi.
No, ilmassa monta on ihmeellistä asiaa, se hämmästyttää, kummastuttaa, vanhaa kulkijaa.
Kun näistä lemmikkielämistä, esimerkiksi Aasista, on puuttu, että se tarvis lajiseuraa,
no se on oon ymmärrettävä, ei ihminenkään tykkää olla jonkun elämän seurassa ainoastaan.
Mutta sitten on paljon näitä lemmikkiä, joilla ei olla, ja seuraa.
Kaärmäistä lähtiää erilaisiin liskoihin.
Mitä nyt on lehdistä saanut lukea?
On mitä erilaisempia elämiä pääsy karkkuun?
Ette?
Eikö ihmisillä ole järkeä päässä ollenkaan?
Ajatella siltä elämän kannalta?
Ette, onko sen kiva olla ainoastaan sen ihmisen seurassa?
Eipä tässä muuta hyvää päivänjatkoa kaikille.
Hei, hei.
Arvoiset kansanradion kuuntelijat, veroja maksava eläkeläinen.
Nyt te, Suomessa, rikkait haluaa, tämä, perintöverot poies, ette muuttavat muuten Suomesta.
Ei tarvitse muuttaa, he varmaan tietävät, indeksirasko mihin voi sijoittaa, ei tarvitse maksaa veroja koskaan.
Me tavalliset maksamme.
Ja miksi?
Osakeyhtiön verotus olisi 1174 voinaa 60 prosenttia, mutta siinä oli vähennyks.
Must, silloin rakennettiin Suomea, hyvinvointia ihmisille, kouluja, palveluita.
Nyt, ko verot on laskettu, ni kuka maksaa.
Ja sitten toisi.
Ei, nämä tuotantoeläimet tuhoaa luontoa, ne on kaivokset, mitkä sen tekee.
Ja tuotantoeläimet, ku nyt alkuperäiset pistätte poies, mistä otaatte tilalle? Älkää luopuva, taisselkaa pienek. Kiitos. Hyvä syksyn odotusta.
Nyt siirrymme Keski-Suomeen. Sieltä yksi tuttuääni muistelee ensimmäistä puheluaan, meidän ohjelmaan.
Ja kun kerran puhelusta on kyse, niin on paikallaan kertoa myös kansaradion puhelinnumero.
Se on nolla, kahdeksan, nolla, nolla, yksi, viisi, neljä, kuusi, neljä.
Ja puhelua soittäälle maksuton, ja muistuksena, että sunnuntaisin, kello 12:30 alkaen, tuossa numerossa vastaa ihmis vastaa ja kolmen tunnin ajan.
No niin, tässä on Mauno Voutilainen pitkästä aikaa Kelan eläkkeellä Jyväskylässä.
Onko totta, että jotkut soittavat kansanradioon vasta ensimmäistä kertaa tulevan ohjelman esittelyssä, niin kuulin vanhemman Rouvan näin sanovan, että hän soittaa nyt ensimmäistä kertaa kansanradioon.
Onko näin, että kun kokee, että on oikein kovasti asiaa, niin sitten soitetaan, vaikka ei olisi ennen soitettu kansanradion tallennukseen?
Kovin monia on ihmisiä ilmeisesti, jotka eivät ole soittaneet vielä ensimmäistäkään kertaa kansanradioon.
Ja minullakin oli sellainen tilanne, en oikein kunnolla muista, että mikä oli se tilanne, ja missä tapahtui, kun soitin ensimmäistä kertaa kansanradion tallennukseen.
Nutta pääministerinä oli Esko Aho, residenttinä oli Martti Ahtisaari, ja minä olin työnhakijan roolissa sillä hetkellä, Jyväskylässä, puretussa talossa, työnhakijana.
Näin, kiitoksia. Ja hyvää sunnuntain jatkoa, ja ne, jotka ovat soittaneet vasta ensimmäisen kerran kansanradion tallennukseen, niin nyt kannattaa soittaa toisen ja kolmanen kerran.
Ensimmäinen, toinen, ja kolmas kerta, kuten hirvas kankaan, huutopaikka keisarin huutokaupassa. Kiitoksia.
Kiitos, Mauno, sinulle. Syksy on saapunut maahan meijä, se kuuluu myös tämän kerran runoissa.
Enen niitä äänimuotoisia teoksia, yksi postikortilla saapunut runo.
Illalla uni saapuu, sumuun saattaa aamulla, tonttu keittää puurot.
Suukotkin antaa, toverin rohkaiseva hymy, työ auttaa jaksamaan.
Kotimatkabussissa, jossa glasarikuskia rentouttaa, kotikynnyksen yli hiiop, ja oman kullan syliin uppoan.
Tällä tavoin meille runoili postikortissa Toivo Koijärvi. Postimerkissä oli muuten Karva Kuono Kolmikko.
Meille kansanridon voi lähettää kortteja ja muuta perinteistä postia osoitteeseen, Kansanradio, PL, 79, 00, 24, Yleisradio.
No heipä hei, nyt on meillä kohta lämmityskausi käsillä, ja hieman on hätää, kuinka meidän sähkön asioiden käy, senpä takia luenkin runo.
Jossa takuu eläkettä, voiko keittää edes vettä.
Sähkön hinta, kun on kova, pörssiyhtiöihin nojaa.
Onko tässä enää järkeä, jos optio on vain tärkeä?
Mielettömyys vallallansa, hytiseeekö koko kansa?
Nyt tarvittaisiin mallia, jossa kohtuttakin voidaan sallia.
Luoja meille energian antaa, vain voittoa vain jotkut kantaa.
Saaden yrisuuren saaliin, se ei mene minun kaaliin.
Yhteinen on luomakunta, siis sähköllekin kohtuu summa, et pyörii vielä yhteiskunta. Kiitos.
Ohamin soittelee hyvää taivää.
Runo marjaa aikaan.
Heti aamulla ylös, kun heräilin.
Pian metsässä marjoja keräilin.
On metsässä tarjolla mustikkaa, on tattia, sientä muhevaa, tuulilauha.
Leodosti puhalteli, tekee syksyä, vielä odotteli.
Onhan jälleen, taas sadonkorjuu on aikaa.
Se on totta, on metsissä, syksyistä taikaa.
Hyvää syksyä, Olavi.
Syksy saapuu.
Pääskyset etelään lähtivät, ja jättivät räystään alle pesän.
Jo näkivät, kauniin Suomen ja kesän.
Hiljalleen vaihtuvat vuoden ajat, kaikilla on aikansa.
Tulevat värikkäät pihlajat, luonto näyttää taikansa.
Jälleen löytyvät punaiset puolukat, kankahalta talon takaa.
Sinne teemme hauskat marjamatkat, taas metsä antejaan jakaa.
Keltaisenä koivu hohtaa, pian lehdet peittävät maan.
Näin syksyy meidät kohtaa, ruskasta nauttia saan.
Sinikka, kiitos.
Kartta uudistus vielä ainakin pohdituttaa.
Ennen viimeisiä puheluita, minä toivitan teille kaikkea hyvää.
Koiviston Lauri kiittää ja kumartaa, kansanradio, jälleen viikon päästä.
Pitkästä aikaa soittaa ja kysellet tuota asiasta, kun puhutaan siitä onnellisimmasta kansasta, että Suomi olisi sellainen.
Kun olisi kiva nähdä se lanketti, missä kerrotaan, minkälainen kysynnyspatteri on esitetty näille, jotka on vastannu ehkä tähän kysymykseen.
Mutta mielestäni se paremminkin ei onnellinen, vai vähän tyytyvä kansa.
Ei me vaarita semmoisia, mitä on noilla isommilla, iso rikkailla tuolla pitkin maailmaa, ettei meil oo kaikkea semmoista, mutta me tyyrymme siihen, mitä meillä ollaan.
Vähempään tyytyväisiä, se johtuu siitä, ei se tarkoita sitä, että me ollaan onnellisempia.
Me tyyrymme siihen, mitä me oon saatu, ja se riittää. Kiitos. Moi.
No, Kari tässä. Kuuntelin tosta radiosta, kartan uudistuksesta, näin. Onko kukaan ikinä miettiny semmoista, että vanhan ajan karttapallothan kertoo realisesti koko jutu? Kannatais varmaan karttapalloja vielummin hommata, kuin tämmösiä paperiniuskoja. Moi.
Hei, kansanradio, siisti tarkoittaa puhdasta, opasti, kansalainen.